مجرد الوصول إلى
منطقة استبعاد تشيرنوبيل هي رحلة غادرة
دمرت العديد من الشوارع والجسور ،
واضطررنا إلى السير على الطرق الوعرة لعبور الأنهار على
الجسور العائمة ،
وصلنا إلى قبة الحبس
لمحطة الطاقة التي انفجرت في عام 1986 ، وهو
أسوأ حادث نووي على الإطلاق
غزت القوات الروسية  هذه المنطقة في
اليوم الأول من حربهم ضد
أوكرانيا واستولت على تشيرنوبيل دون الكثير
من القتال
الآن بعد أن غادر الروس
وزير الداخلية الأوكراني دنيس
موناسترسكي أخذنا إلى تشيرنوبيل
وما وجدناه كان
مقلقًا الروس قاموا بسجن موظفي الأمن
داخل المصنع
أخبرنا وزير الداخلية بأنه لا يوجد
ضوء طبيعي ولا هواء نقي ولا
اتصالات ، لذلك احتفظ الروس بـ 169
سجينًا أوكرانيًا هنا طوال الوقت
الذي احتجزوا فيه هذا المكان ، ثم عندما
غادر الروس قاموا بنهب المكان ونهبوه
بين السجناء ضباط شرطة
الحرس الوطني  أعضاء
وجنود وزير الداخلية الأوكراني أخبرني أن
الروس لديهم الآن تا  أخبرهم بالذهاب إلى
روسيا وهم لا يعرفون كيف يفعلون
عندما وصلت إلى هنا ، لقد صدمت ،
كما يقول ، لكن مرة أخرى فقط أدرك أنه
لا يوجد روس جيدون ولا شيء
جيد يأتي من الروس ، إنها دائمًا
قصة مرتبطة بالضحايا  الدم
والعنف ما نراه هنا هو
مثال حي على السلوك الفاضح في
منشأة نووية
بينما سُمح للموظفين الفنيين بالمحطة
بمواصلة العمل ،
ويقول الأوكرانيون إن القوات الروسية كانت تفتقر إلى
الأمان
النووي وعندما دخلنا المنطقة بقيت القوات الروسية
وعملت  فجأة
ينطلق إنذار جهاز قياس المستندات من
مستويات الإشعاع المتزايدة ، ذهبوا إلى
الغابة الحمراء وجلبوا الإشعاع
هنا على أحذيتهم ، يقول هذا الحارس الوطني في
كل مكان آخر طبيعي
فقط هذه الأرضية مشعة ، أسأل في
كل مكان على ما يرام ولكن هنا ليس
طبيعيًا ، نعم يقول  زاد الإشعاع
هنا لأنهم عاشوا
هنا وذهبوا في كل مكان على
أحذيتهم وملابسهم ، فسألت نعم والآن
أخذوا الإشعاع  أيون معهم ، دعنا
نخرج من هنا ، أقول إن
ما يسمى بالغابة الحمراء هي واحدة من
أكثر المناطق تلوثًا في العالم
وخاصة التربة ، حيث
أصدرت الحكومة الأوكرانية لقطات طائرة بدون طيار
تظهر على ما يبدو أن الروس حفروا
مواقع قتالية هناك
المشغل النووي الأوكراني.  تقول النباتات إن هؤلاء
الجنود الروس كان من الممكن أن يكونوا قد تعرضوا
لكميات كبيرة من الإشعاع ،
فقد ذهبنا إلى حافة منطقة الغابة
الحمراء ووجدنا حصة غذائية عسكرية روسية
على الأرض عندما قمنا
بحمل مقياس الدقة لإغلاق صواريخ الإشعاع
إلى حوالي 50 ضعفًا فوق المستويات الطبيعية
تقول أوكرانيا إن سلوك روسيا في هذه
الحرب يمثل تهديدًا للسلامة النووية في
أوروبا ، فإن محطة تشيرنوبيل للطاقة النووية
لم تعمل منذ سنوات ،
ولكن بالطبع هذا الحبس يحتاج إلى
المراقبة 24 7 وكذلك
الوقود النووي المستهلك في هذا المركب أيضًا
وليس فقط في تشيرنوبيل
أطلقت القوات الروسية صواريخ على
أكبر محطة للطاقة النووية في أوروبا بالقرب من
زابوريزيا في سو.
أوكرانيا ويحتلونها الآن أخبرني وزير الطاقة الأوكراني أنه
يجب على المجتمع الدولي أن يتدخل أعتقد
أنه تأثير كبير وهذا هو
فعل الإرهاب النووي ، لكن
ما يفعلونه في تشيرنوبيل قريب
من حدود بيلا الروسية التي
استخدمها الجيش الروسي  هذا الطريق كواحد من طرقها الرئيسية
لمهاجمة العاصمة الأوكرانية ،
يقول وزير الداخلية إن بلاده بحاجة إلى
المزيد من الأسلحة للدفاع عن هذه الحدود
اليوم ، فالحدود بين الاستبداد
والديمقراطية تمر خلف ظهورنا.
ويخشى الأوكرانيون أنهم قد يضطرون
للقتال هنا مرة أخرى قريبًا حيث
يجدد الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين
قواته ويواصل تعريض هذه الأمة
والسلامة النووية في أوروبا للخطر.